[Music]
the show is very popular of Breaking Bad
what kind of fans you getting I mean
probably uh you have a lot of fans but
some of them something a little strange
yes yeah you do get some you do get some
interesting fans yeah I'm always
concerned about I'm always we always
wonder about the fans who say you know
I'm never sure who to root for yeah you
know it's like really the guy's a psycho
killer he's really did poison a
ten-year-old kid and you're not sure who
the root yeah hand on that right yeah
Walter White
just about anybody else in the in the
cast yeah yeah nobody consider this a
we're so invested in Walter yeah at this
point we've watched him develop and grow
over all this time so you can get a
little conflicted at times I guess you
can I don't know I'm gonna be dead all
right tell us specifically you get some
fans that are have interesting websites
we do you know there's I did a shower
scene where I you know get a little bare
chested and there are certain fans out
there who like that kind of teddy bear
look mature goodness no I I believe the
terminology is bears wherever I can get
attention Conan I'll take it hey you
know they don't understood me either
science I have other sites and other
fans Breaking Bad when you audition for
this show you thought it was a comedy I
did it's not well it's interesting
because I can do I know I can understand
that comedy but it's a very very dark
comedy but you weren't sure how to play
it in the audition we we had Vince
Gilligan on the show we see the creator
of the show and when you went and
auditioned for him one of the most
important I just is you ever gonna have
you didn't know how to play it
right well I was I was like conflicted I
was like this is funny to me but I could
tell you know maybe agents whatever said
it was a it was a drama so I was like
now I'm gonna go with my gut and I'm
gonna make it funny and yeah we did yeah
well I I think one of the things that I
have loved so much is that when the show
started you seemed like probably at
first I thought okay this will be like a
two dimensional comic relief character
and then very quickly it starts to
unravel that you're very good at what
you do which makes it's so valuable to
the show yeah thanks appreciate that
yeah and now what that was all me but
that was all you yes you added that
wasn't in the writing no no the writers
doing with red wings um crazy you
you've played cops for most of your
careers that I have I used to call
myself the the alphabet actor yeah CIA
DEA FBI
you name it up plated right so you just
come into it and you eat so now you must
almost feel like you know all the jargon
you you have the authority and bearing
of a law enforcement I mean you could
arrest us both now and I without a badge
yeah I would try would believe that you
have write authority exact I have
friends who like you guys were talking
earlier about drugs and stuff if there
ever a short on cash and I just walked
into a bar you know people just here you
go you know just all the bad stuff they
got just lays they just put it on the
can you sell it very nice we could work
sell it yeah solid all right I guess I'm
a real rube huh
okay what you know no one knows you
don't know do you think the final
showdown for this series which is coming
up in the next season do you think it's
gonna be tank versus wall you think
that's where the showdown yeah I don't I
I don't know what it's gonna be
I just hope I'm alive that's really it's
a show where you never know you never
know if you're on silver spoon to The
Cosby Show you know your characters
coming back speak but but on your show
you never know you could get the script
one day and yeah just gone I think I
think I hope Hank you know goes little
gangster himself you know I'm saying
little Hank stop yeah you know right
yeah Heisenberg pull out my gas whose
iceberg now [ __ ]
[Applause]
did I just go hang stuff
fade to black Oh who's Heisenberg now
yeah that's a yeah that's the most
essential shooting if the human being
I've ever seen that's right see I
suppose that's the most unprofessional
gun handling but it ain't going gangster
exactly I love it